et j'ai quelque chose pour toi oublier
pour la maison blanche son père un
entretien pour travailler dans les
services secrets
c'est trop bien john key qu'est ce qui
vous attire dans les services secrets
je crois qu'il ya aucun boulot plus
important qu'elle protégeait le
président à la fois que vous aviez du
mal à voir la moyenne ne vous occupez
pas de la jante aide si ce cher à jean
todt continue à glousser il va falloir
que je m'en occupe pas
c'est bien moche et oui y'a des chances
je sais comment ça il faut d'abord
qu'ils discutent entre eux si vous nous
rejoignez c'est une édition spéciale en
direct
c'est john key
je suis dans la maison blanche alva vous
avez là si on tient le président dans la
bibliothèque
c'est une bibliothèque non-droit pas ça
c'est vraiment débile et monsieur le
président
au fait tu vois c'est john kerry james
sawyer
vous devez mettre le président sécurité
via ma fille qui comptent sur moi je la
laisserai pas tomber explosion au
capitole était une diversion
ça doit se jouer un peu au niveau lequel
il n'y a qu'une façon de le découvrir
tout ce que vous ferez je le saurai
ça je le fais pas
oui
vous êtes un pacifique mais il va
falloir vous en servir été un carton
carreno
je n'ai plus le lance roquettes pourquoi
et comment un peu paumé un lance
roquettes
ne bougez plus petit
l'auto tune